[Music]
there is a lot of information out there
for people applying to business school I
know I went through a lot of it some of
them hopeful some of it not yeah what
are the best resources for applying to
Stanford and I think you make a good
point there's a lot of misinformation
out there as well we really believe the
best information start with start with
what we put out there on the website
what's nice about it now is there's lots
of conversations with students out there
so you can learn about what it's
actually like from the students much
more I think that's more interesting
than hearing it from admissions as well
as there's you know profile information
tips about the application start there
but one of the most important things you
can do is also go to an information
session and we do about a hundred of
them around the globe and the reason for
that is you'll get a panel of four
usually three to five recent graduates
and they can tell you we but we believe
that Stanford can be transformational
for you both and what you learn but also
how you develop so you can actually
listen to how this experience has
impacted people in their own lives both
from how they went through as well as
what they're doing now when they
graduate so I think that's one of the
best ways you can truly be inspired but
also get your questions answered and if
we're we're not coming to your hometown
then go to the web we have a virtual one
to where you can hear students talking
and recent alumni about their
experiences